I love hearing from the audience on all
of our different platforms but one in
which the discussion amongst audience
members continues to grow is on our
reddit discussion forum which you can
find at david pakman.com slash read it
more than two thousand viewers and
listeners are now regularly suggesting
stories arguing with each other
criticizing me complimenting me
criticizing Pat complimenting Pat more
compliments for patent for me actually
I've noticed interesting enough uh uh
here are a few discussions that have
gone on over the last few days on our
reddit discussion forum one post asking
about the whether there are any poles on
the Trump human Molotov cocktail vote
and FBI is James Comey uh interfering
with the election and there's a
discussion going on about uh whether we
have polling about those issues very
interesting discussion another topic
from our reddit discussion forum what
would the election results have been
like if people stopped and appreciated
the fact that Trump actually had a real
chance of winning that is an interesting
question and an interesting one that is
being discussed on the David Pakman show
reddit discussion forum another topic
from reddit Hillary Clinton sponsored a
bill in 2005 supporting jail time for
flag desecration later she declined to
support an amendment to require such a
thing she's also against legalization of
weed our choice really was about voting
for the lesser of two evils and there's
sort of an interesting back and forth in
this thread about whether Hillary's
position on the whole flag burning thing
is even relevant cuz we're talking about
what Donald Trump said this week not
what Hillary Clinton said uh in some
interesting back and forth about that
also from reddit a comment about our uh
dog related segment earlier this week I
commented about how when I was home over
the Thanksgiving break i was watching my
dad's dog my dad's dog was on some of my
facebook live feeds and a lot of people
interestingly Pat really like that it's
important not to understand ur a state
the interest of the audience in dogs and
cats every time that comes up people
seem very engaged yeah it's a very
interesting topic I'm sure
and people also want to delve into your
personal life a little bit you think
that's what it is and maybe people are
just to see how I deal with having uh
what I refer to as adderall dog when I
food my hands at home a lot of people
emailed me about that they really like
the adderall dog and I think this is the
last one has anyone had a bizarre dream
which featured david pakman and louis MO
tommy i'm not going to tell you anything
else that's discussed in this thread I i
will leave it for you to check it out
because I don't know if you've looked at
this thread passing the description it
is fascinating it is endlessly
fascinating what people are talking
about and and let me just talk tell you
that power rangers are mentioned in this
discussion thread so david pakman.com
slash reddit please subscribe now more
than 2,000 audience members are
participating there david pakman.com
slash r ed di t